who do you think you are
do you know what i mean yeah
[Music]
right guys follow us on youtube or
subscribe to us on youtube follow us on
twitter
follow us on instagram and patreon we
are doing the mission
1k
so if you don't know now you know
basically we are trying to hit a
thousand
pounds on patreon so we can drop
two episodes a week um the thousand
pounds means
jim will have a lot less time at work um
he can come up more often
we will be able to have a chance to
record more often and then yeah we'll be
able to release more videos and more
content for you guys
so the quicker we get that done but the
well the quicker we reach 1k the quicker
we can get the two vids a week
up yeah man running gang um
that is the plan obviously merch is
poppin
merch is poppin new release is coming
soon before the tail end of this year
um we've got great ideas and if you guys
have some ideas as well hit us up
dm us message us because ideally the
merch is for you it's not for us
so yeah we had a nice little graphic
designer hit us up the other day yeah we
did
we did she just did dude doodled us up
something in her free time and
it might make it might make the lick she
doesn't i don't i'm not gonna say
i'm not gonna say you might make the car
it might not don't get gas
don't get excited the suggestion is
there mum but yeah man yeah man yeah man
um so fun fact oh yeah
go on alright did you know your tongue
knows exactly what something would feel
like
if you lick it even before you've licked
it
you can look at anything in this room
and your tongue knows
your brain will tell your tongue what
it's going to feel like that makes
perfect
i'm doing it as we speak anyone right
now listen and watch and do it
your tongue will render the feeling in
your brain
before it's everlasting before you
there's there are millions of things
you've never licked do you know what i
mean yeah
you know what it's gonna be i've not
looked anything in this room and i know
exactly what
everything's gonna feel like it's crazy
right that is weird it's crazy right
fun fact of the day mad
mad i'm just looking around like yeah
you know exactly what everything's going
to feel like the weird thing is
even if i don't know what it's going to
feel like to my hands yeah i'm looking
around
but if i imagine it on my tongue i'm
like i already know a quick graze of the
tongue
yeah yeah you'd know exactly what it's
gonna feel like that's crazy
fair play or very nice yeah man all
right
cool that's a little fun fact for you
guys to start off i like the fun facts
i'm a fan
i think yeah you should keep that up g
i'm a fan um
so ouch um
as you may have noticed it's getting a
bit chilly
it's getting a bit chilly it is getting
cold and like i've always said like
i hate winter i hate it and um summer
makes me happy
this summer made me it did make me happy
this summer made me uncomfortable
it was hot some i was used to being
always the guy that was like big man i'm
never gonna complain when it's hot
because i hate when it's cold so like
i can't just be complaining all the time
like the there but there were days
and nights it was the nights it's the
nights we all know it's the nights
bro england's not equipped is it
england's not quit
we don't have air con yeah there's not a
yard i've been to in this country that
has
air con yeah we don't have aircon
anywhere here fan and window that's all
we got wind
there was no breeze fam for weeks
for weeks i was dying that's yuma's
problem i've always had a fan i've
always had a fan in my room since i was
a kid i don't know why
and every single time i used to put it
on at like
during like winter times or whatever or
everyone to every time because i used to
keep it in my room especially when i
moved up here the first time there was
yeah
yeah i had nowhere else to put it yeah i
mean come that three
four weeks maybe a month of when it's
scorching hot who's laughing now well i
had a fan i've got we had i
i i've got fans because i had a fan
here my bedside day was here and i had a
fan here one tower thing
yeah it was blur in my face fam i woke
up on my eyes was sticking
because i sleep with my eyes open have
you never noticed
my eyes don't close properly when i'm
asleep so you know what have i ever
noticed because obviously you've seen me
asleep before
some people have noticed i don't think
i've ever yes i've known i've clearly
never noticed that
so when i'm asleep when you say open do
you mean like a jar yeah like a jar no
i'm not like
you know it's dead
that's funny um
that's funny so um
oh what does it say yeah they're just
like slitting yeah
so okay okay my eyes roll up when i'm
asleep in here
as i think most peoples are so yeah when
i'm asleep my eyes are all up
but my eyelids just creep up with it a
little bit okay so
people look to me in the past and be
like bro your eyes are open
and i'm like cool i'm asleep leave me
alone
so as if you guys are having this
conversation while you're asleep
anyway so i put the fan here in my face
yeah i woke up the next day my eyeballs
were cold fam well i
i couldn't see for minutes and um
it was tough but um it reminded me i was
thinking
of like everything i [ __ ] hate about
winter i was on my drive up here yeah i
was thinking about it yeah i was
thinking everything i hate about winter
yeah
and it was actually making me depressed
like
scraping your car obviously you don't
have this problem in a minute but
scraping your [ __ ] car on a cold day
like i remember days of where i've had
like if i've had to
work early shifts early shifts i
remember when i used to work at like
five my shift you start like 5 00 am fam
getting outside i know everyone's asleep
pitch warm
pitch and i'm just shuffling into my car
scraping and the scrape it's loud fam
and you can know someone near
the car is thinking shut the [ __ ] up
shut the [ __ ] up
um and then you get in the car steering
wheel's freezing cold
and you just sit there waiting for it to
heat up fam it's a [ __ ] nightmare
it's a [ __ ] nightmare it's tired i'm
sick of it
i'm sick of it do you not think it's
crazy how we can actually
notice global warming it's it's it's
[ __ ] right now
because from what let's say january to
when did it get like hot hot like july
it was crazy hot in july right
um and then it's just been cold in
august
there was no gradual change just went
cold it rained
for like three days straight and then
it's been cold ever since it makes
no sense yeah it makes no sense it
doesn't make any okay
and by the way this is in the uk so
whoever's listening elsewhere
i don't know what it's like over there
man in la are thinking what are you on
about this is the uk
like uk just it just rains in manchester
as well as the worst because
i i won't even explain just google it
it's actually with the pennines and the
sea
and not the sea but like the water in it
it rains a lot in man
a lot in manchester anyway it rains it
rains in the sea oh what's going on
it's cause it's warm in there now these
flies are [ __ ] bright they're just
hatching in it
it's brave they're brave um fam
have you ever tried to have a wank with
a cold hand
i don't really think i noticed the
temperature of my hand when i'm trying
to walk oh right not really
i don't know i probably haven't scared
the living right oh my god of me
oh my god the living christ out of me
big man i didn't know you were here i
didn't know you were in the building
first of all
so for the audio listeners and vid um i
can't even speak
i can't even be did you hear me screech
because you didn't see it fan because
you said scare the living life at me i
thought you still talk about flies
no and then i looked and saw a leg
i screamed like a [ __ ] i i because we
said this morning
i thought bella was at work yes i
genuinely thought you were i didn't know
you were
alive i said is she here you've been
kipping fam
[Laughter]
jesus christ that's the scariest
experience i quite remember what i was
going to say
i can't even remember what i was going
to say [ __ ] god my heart left my
chest
um i was saying like have you ever had a
wank with a cold hand
you said you didn't i don't know you
clearly never had like a
a rush wank oh i have i don't know if my
hands have been cold
you'd know you would know i'm talking
cold i'm talking like numb fingers cold
no
no it's horrible it sounds horrible it's
the worst thing you shouldn't do it but
sometimes you have to do it it's the
worst thing anyway so
it reminded me i was thinking
about one time i had this one-night
stand with this girl right
out and it was freezing
that night okay freezing it wasn't in
december or january it's like a [ __ ]
cold
cold so it was the weirdest thing so
basically
yeah i don't know how many i must have
been i don't even know oh maybe i was
like 20
maybe 21 early so i'm out
in northampton right one more boys and
this one girl's around i don't know who
she was or whatever yeah
and then i was chatting to one of my
boys this is the corniest situation ever
it's not going to be sick thinking about
it attached to one of the boys i'm very
reminded i'm drunk
at this point it's the end of the night
cornea sich yeah
and then um she's there and she's
talking talking and my
mind my boy's there and he was just
repelling [ __ ]
like he couldn't [ __ ] i think he was a
virgin at this point okay and he just
couldn't smash
really so this girl's trying to give him
tips
on how to draw things okay and she's
going going and i'm like yeah she's
talking about kissing and all that stuff
and i'm just listening and then i'm like
yeah yeah yeah yeah and he was like oh
how am i supposed to just like kick us a
girl and i was like big man to be fair
these times some girls just let you
lips them just let you lips them
and she was like they do actually do
yeah like she was like this man that i
don't know all the time
it's easy for a girl though family is
always easy and i was and then
my drunk self thinking my confidence is
up up yeah i was like
swear what's going on
lipster lipstick on the spot my friend
vex at this point obviously because he's
like oh just my
case in point yeah i'm trying i'm trying
to get coaching and how to get [ __ ] and
my boy is swooping in and getting [ __ ]
yeah
so me and her start lips and she wasn't
even buff
okay she was okay and then um so i'm
like haha cool cool cool so we
we move on we're walking and she's all
right cool i'm about to dip
i'm right safe she's like are you coming
and i was like
gang um yes i am fam it's freezing oh
god so we walked for like 20 minutes and
it's
the coldest night ever and then um
she was wearing like a skirt and you
know when you see girls on a cold cold
cold night and they're wearing dresses
and skirts and [ __ ] and you think [ __ ]
you must be [ __ ]
freezing it must be chaps because i'm
dying yeah and i'm wrapped up
so we get back to hers she turns off the
light bread and my she didn't have any
lamps
and it was the darkest room for starters
darkest room and i'm like alright cool
so we're trying to navigate navigate
navigate
find the face find the body
find palm everything so smashing and fam
all i remember i specifically remember
this girl and i don't remember her name
i don't remember where she lived i don't
remember anything but i remember
this girl's body was cold fam
like numbingly cold oh my god so every
time i'm trying to pipe
obviously the palms is warm but the
cheeks
i'm trying to clap cheeks and it's
freezing
and i'm there like ah
[Laughter]
she's really thinking my mother
she thinks you're making noise because i
think because the palms are sweet
nah that was freezing no way every clap
i was just there like
[Laughter]
i was so cold it was the worst night of
my life
and then i kept and i remember i was
broke stone cold broke
and i didn't want anything to do with
this girl the next day okay
so i woke up early yeah she must have
gone toilet yeah and i build
taupes yeah i fell toes yeah and i was
like
i need money now i need money
now fam and i know i don't know why i
built him yeah but he i just knew he
would sort me out yeah yeah no questions
i have no questions
no questions that's it you would have
been like like
you would have been like what are you on
about don't ring me at nine o'clock in
the morning on a [ __ ] sunday cause
would you want money for
tell me like he did he just knew i need
money now
the manager said how much i was like run
me 20 please that's hilarious i'll pay
you back tomorrow
and he was like calm fam sent 20. told
him the story in the cab ride home
and that was that um but yeah don't ever
bang a ting on a cold night film
maybe have a shower or bath or whatever
it was the worst experience of my life
it there's less experience in my life
i'm dreading this year's winter
gee it's going to be cold this year
because it's cold in or it's we're in
august no september it's going to be
to give them freezing jobs and it was
winter because you have to do it like
that
it was it's a nightmare honestly my toe
would shrink
he's a man i'll shiver oh my days i hope
the
microphone picked that up my tool was
hilarious shrivel cuz it's hilarious
that's [ __ ] hilarious oh my days have
you ever speaking of shrivel tools
have you ever this is a i refuse to
believe this doesn't happen to every man
okay
have you ever done like i don't know
been nervous or done like an
athletic activity yeah and then
had a look at your piece
like through my clothes not through your
clothes just like either felt it or seen
it
probably or been like super cold
probably yeah yeah if mine's like this
big
no i think i think every man's one is
especially when it's freezing
for freezing sam i remember the first
time that ever happened to me that i
noticed
was when sports day in school okay so me
and my boys being like yeah ten then i
signed up yeah we're talking like year
nine year ten yeah so me and my boys
decided that
it would be funny because the way we had
a hundred meter sprint it wasn't
it wasn't like a big prank ready for my
day we thought it would be funny because
basically the way it was
you're outside in the field we've got
the 100 meter sprint yeah but then where
it ends off kind of at the end of the
field okay so you can actually kind of
run
into school from there as well okay it's
a straight line into school
okay and we were all in the start and
i'm nervous as [ __ ] and we're like
i need a piss so i must say i need a
pierce brother and he every the other
like two other man were like i need a
[ __ ] business one of the bedrooms was
like
wouldn't it be funny if we just finished
100 meter sprint and just keep running
in school and go have a piss
okay i was like yeah let's do that and
i'm nervous anyway because i'm thinking
the teacher's gonna kill me
i don't know why i don't think they're
gonna kill me so we have the 100 meter
sprint dart bam
bam bang run in go to the toilet and fam
i grabbed my tool
and it was i can't tell you how small it
was
it was like thumb and yeah thumb and
pinky pinching it together
so that i could appear so it's the
smallest it's the smallest thing you've
seen
it's a small i was thinking no girl
could ever see this
and then randomly while i'm pissing my
boy in the cubicle next to me is like
human can i ask you a question i was
like what am i
like is your dick small right now i felt
i screamed
at the top of my leg i was like yes yes
it's tiny what's going on he's almost
gone
i don't know i don't know
that's curiosity fam because grown men
wouldn't ask that question now
but when you're when you're curious
about what your body's doing you're like
you man let me can i ask you manta man
fam what's going on
i remember once another time that
happened
in front of a woman okay was when i got
sdi test
okay oh you had to pull out and piss or
pull it out and like she swabbed she
[ __ ] swapped it she [ __ ] stopped
it so
do you remember when we were in uni we
used to get sci tests all the time yeah
yeah no one swapped me
ever as a piss in the pot they might
take some blood
and then that was the end of it yeah fam
one time i want to get tested just a
routine check
when was this how old were you oh
because i feel like you've told me this
before
probably i was like probably 24 25 you
told me this before
fam it rings a bell oh my god one lady's
she gave me the pot to piss in and i'm
like gang and she's like all right cool
come and lay down
on the bed and i was like swear
man swear well african lady said i'll
come and sit down and lie down on the
bed i'm like swear
in the clinic you don't give a single
[ __ ]
you don't give a single [ __ ] you don't
know what i've got
oh jesus and then fam she's like cool
like underwear off and obviously i'm
still thinking bro okay
if i'm lied down my tool's fine i i've
never
experienced anything like this my tool's
healthy
she pulls out this it's not have you
ever been swabbed
no it's not a swab no it's not swab i've
only done the pisting it's like all
right cool you know when um
you're a kid and you have those little
bubble things where you dip it in the
washing up liquid and you blow it in the
little hole
yes imagine that but like tiny
so it's a tiny one of them like the the
the tip of a needle like the other end
of the needle yeah like the back end of
a needle
but bigger than that a plastic one
fam she draws that out and i'm like
what's that
i found she grips my tool my man said
nah
he reclused
he went down so she had to like
juggle it up you know i mean she had to
like pull at it
what is that she said is calm just
gripped it squeezed it with vigor
shoved it down there i welped
i whelped nah it was the most painful
thing that's ever happened to me
and she shoved it twisted it and yanked
it out
i was screaming nah the thought of that
is make
i i feel like i could feel it i mean
yeah you're getting tingles yeah
fam it was the most excruciating
experience of my life
i went to smacker and then after i had
to get my blood done i hate needles as
it is
yeah hate needles as it is i had to get
my blood done after that
and then they rang me the next day so
they [ __ ] up my bloods like they got
me mixed up or they lost it or something
they said you need to come and get your
bus done again
and i was like i'm not coming in i'm not
coming in never like this is hiv
talk like you need to come in i was like
fam i'll take my chances
i'll take my chances with the hiv you're
not touching me again with another
needle
not after yesterday i don't give a [ __ ]
nah it was the worst [ __ ] experience
[ __ ] that i hated it i've never i've
only ever done the pisting
the pistons where it's at i've never un
obviously in blood
i've never ever ever hadn't had a swab
ever
nightmare living and breathing a
nightmare i remember her face
vividly and this was like five six years
ago one said
lay down like swear
you don't give a [ __ ]
you don't give a [ __ ] that's funny
yeah bro that's uh oh god that's it
sounds painful
it sounds painful it was very painful i
wasn't
a fan it's very [ __ ] painful
oh my god it sounds painful
so yeah man sorry i had to go through
that it's calm g
these things happen in it it's never
happened since
i don't get tested anymore really
what's the deal with johnny's anyway
let's have a real discussion
whoever's making johnny's what kind of
profit margins are they turning over
it's
probably a lot it has to be a lot less
it has to be no one's wearing condoms
anymore
there has to be a lot less
because it's it's [ __ ] it let's
let's just boil it down to what it
really is condoms are [ __ ]
they're so and the funny thing about
condoms sorry to start with you the
funny did stop me
i can tell i could [ __ ] tell you did
start with me the funny thing about
condoms is
there's nothing funny about connors
we're gone go
go go go god if
i've said it to you before i've said it
on here before if
i'm [ __ ] a chick like ad hoc like we
[ __ ] ad hockey
and let's say i've been [ __ ] other
people as well and she knows it and then
i come back to [ __ ] this same girl
and i draws for a condom she'll be
offended
wait say that again so i'm [ __ ] a
chick normally yeah like when we've got
no relationship we're just [ __ ] we're
cool
raw raw yeah being [ __ ] wrong been
[ __ ] being [ __ ]
yeah but she knows and we both know
we're both [ __ ] other people
because we're just we're just singing
we're single yeah
and i come back and [ __ ] up with a dom
she's offended
yeah she's offended we're trying to
protect each other
but she's offended of course there's
something about a dom that is the least
sexy thing possible it's
it's like again like exactly we say like
as soon as you put dom on after you've
been [ __ ] someone
she could know like obviously she could
know you'd be [ __ ] other people
but as soon as you run back on wednesday
and put a condom on
all she can think about is you've got
chlamydia from some hoe you [ __ ]
yesterday and you don't want to give it
to me like you're not [ __ ] me with
that thing
whereas if you just [ __ ] her again
she and gave her chlamydia she would
have been like you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's a it's a lose-lose it is a loser
please lose
it's a loser that's a good point it's a
lose-lose
dom's are dead they are they are
terrifyingly dead
i'm like what the [ __ ] do you think i'm
gonna give you something that's why you
put in a condom so you don't want your
girl to get whatever you think i have
because i'm being [ __ ] other guys
so then that that's why i get offended
because that happened to me
during our chat big man if you're going
to chat come and chat no i'm not i'm
just your friend um give me that example
i remember how angry i was and how much
it didn't want to [ __ ] a guy anymore
but i had to when you
put the condom on and we had never
bought a [ __ ] condom
well you thought because he put a condom
on that he was worried about you
giving him something yeah because he
knew i was talking other guys
and then he was like oh you are going to
give me
something i'm going to give the girl
something because i have clearly have
something that's why he needs to put a
condom with me
because he doesn't trust me
hmm you've gotta have some
you gotta have i don't know man
you gotta have some bravado to think
that do you know what i mean
i would more i would more think about i
would never ever think about a girl
giving me something
after that prove about two girls where i
thought i'm swimming in
a swamp now i'm swimming in dark waters
that's disgraceful
two girls in my life where i i know one
of them yeah oh you know one of them
yeah i know i know one of them for sure
a hundred percent i don't know if i know
the other one but i know one of them for
sure
that's eleven and yeah i was never
thinking
apart from obviously though those two
because they were absolutely filthy it's
not even that they were sleeping with
other people that's
what they did for a living basically
yeah that's what it felt like um
apart from that i've never thought oh
well
like she's gonna give me something so i
better burn down one
i've always thought what you just said
like i don't i don't want to be worried
about
giving a girl something so i want to
strap up but um
yeah and the funny thing is as well
with the i think the offense starts to
build up when
let's say you meet a chick for the first
time are you [ __ ] her raw for the first
time
and you've been [ __ ] so the first
time you do use the dom is like
why didn't you use it my initial thought
is that they think
why didn't you use a dom in the first
place yeah but then with the same breath
it's like
you knew i didn't use a dom in the first
place so why are we talking about it now
why can't i use a dom now
yeah do you know what i mean so it's
kind of again it's a lose-lose i had a
um i could talk with a girl one time
who was in a relationship
and her man must have
i think they do a long distance thing
and her man must have messaged her
and she said they just do a pull-out
thing they're doing like a pull-out
thing for like a year
risky business i did that pulling out
so dead it's so dead
sometimes in a girl is single-handedly
one of the best
one of the best feelings in the world it
is but anyways i actually don't know
what's
sometimes i don't know what's worth
wearing a condom or pulling out
wearing a condom 100 hundred percent
we're unaccompanied
that we're in a condom sucks for the
entirety
but when i know you're not an insight
yeah yeah you're my nut is
equivalent to the experience of sex of
having so let's say
there's a spectrum of sex from zero to
ten when i'm as soon as i'm wearing a
condom
i'm not getting a better [ __ ] than a
four yeah like regardless how amazing
this girl is i'm not having better sex
than a four
but my nut is also a four but when
pulling out i could be having
10 secs and the nuts building and i'm
thinking i can't wait to come yeah
and then you have to pull out and it
immediately drags me down to like a two
it drops yeah
and i'm just like so [ __ ] i know what
you mean it just doesn't feel great
i think if i have to put i leave it
literally to the last the last
that's risky for me as soon as you
because when there are times where i
pull out and i pull out too early so i'm
just they're like like trying to talk
all right yeah yeah yeah i don't do that
anymore
i don't do that anymore which i don't do
anyway which i have to put when i have
to pull out
i [ __ ] wait to the last
the last little gasp the last little
girl pulled out of him
fire on her chest bro but no probably
not he's dead
pulling out his damn like do you
remember twilight
the twilight movies yeah do you remember
like
you know they had this thing where it's
like sucking blood like once they start
sucking blood they physically cannot
stop like you have to get dragged
and that's why like my man refused to
ever bite bella or whatever it's like
i'm never i'm never gonna
i'm never gonna be able to stop that's
how i am with pulling out
that's why i can't leave it to the last
last minute okay because if i leave it
yeah you're not pulling out
i'm not pulling out yeah or i'll
convince myself
that i haven't known it yet
that's the dumbest thing no no but like
you know what you said
you leave it to the last thing i've had
times where like okay
so when you nut do you ever have the
initial like initial spasm
yeah and then there's like a half second
pause and then you come
yeah yeah so sometimes i justify like oh
i'm calm
yeah that first one it's just the first
tingle like there's nothing to know
that's probably the most powerful one
it is that shoots straight up to egg
number three
it shoots straight in there [ __ ] yeah if
i'm pulling out's dead connor was dead
but like the biggest the worst secret
that should have never come out when's
when you found out girls hate condoms
just as much as guys like them
i wish i never learned girls hate
condoms
hate probably a lot more than guys hate
condoms because obviously
they're getting penetrated so they
literally feel the difference
inside them yeah true
i'm gonna feel it we don't get
penetrated well do you know me yeah
unless you want to
some people do some people do that's
that's your business
um yeah like
yeah no one should have said when i was
younger girls were a lot more adamant
for me
to wear one mm-hmm these times
but you lost you lost your virginity
without kind of correct oh yeah yeah and
so did i so it's hard for me to
build up the tolerance to you or it was
harder for me to build up the tolerance
to use a condom yeah it was never
routine for me
to be putting on sex education i don't
even i can't remember doing sex
education in school i don't remember
i [ __ ] do i think the thing is what
year did you do in
oh i don't know yeah i
i believe it or not we did one sort of
thing in like primary school
in like year six i hope i didn't because
i don't remember anyway it was weird but
there was no condoms or nothing like
that i think it was just like a brief
overview okay
and then maybe like year eight or nine
okay i feel like maybe i would have done
it if i was in year eight year nine in
england because remember
i've always said from year eight to year
ten i was in nigeria yeah yeah when i
came back
i did i finished off the attendant did
year 11. okay
never ever remember dinner i know i
didn't do it no i remember i know i
didn't do sex education like in that
context
yeah yeah no i didn't yeah so
every time i think we've spoken about
this on here before every time i use the
condom it was popped
yeah yeah because i didn't i didn't get
trained on this you did in fact the
amount of times you've told me that your
connors pop
i'm like what are you doing sometimes in
my head i'm like you must blow into it
and then flap it on and you've got some
massive air bubble at the top
like you you pop them they they popped
for
bad and this is when i was making a
obviously i was a lot younger i was
making a much more conscious effort to
use condoms
and then every time it pops the feeling
i would get when i do like two
penetrations without everything but i'm
thinking
why am i you this feels fantastic
what are we playing at fam i remember it
it feels so different
it's so quick so different so quick um i
remember
when i was speaking of sex education
there was like a weird
how do you say it i guess it's like a
clinic or something like a weird
stop-off point that you could go for
teenagers
if you wanted to learn some such
education okay it was like the weirdest
shadiest little room in like a back
alley street
where in the town that i live okay and i
remember
me and the girl i was seeing were trying
to get into it
and she was like oh and they give you
free condoms there right okay so i
didn't have money
i didn't have money to be buying durex
directs are [ __ ] expensive as well
they're like eight pound nine pound for
like a box of whatever
it's like the duracell of condoms yeah
fam and i'm like i
i didn't have money for that so she goes
to me like right
if we go to this place um they'll give
us free condoms and i was like
cool so what you just rock up and say i
want some condoms and she was like i
don't know like we're just gonna have to
go
it's the worst situation so we went in
there and we're like cool we need to go
and
like some woman at receptions oh hi can
i help and like all right cool
we want like some condoms and she was
like oh okay cool well we just need to
like sit down with like mike
uh and he'll talk you through it and i
was like you know he's gonna tell me if
you're what fam
fam ugh so we sit down with mike
yeah mike's some white guy so a picture
he's a big
white guy big he's fat yeah big fat
white guy
with glasses bald and he's sweating
profusely oh
jesus he's sweating profusely he looks
like the grossest person
and he's like sits us down and he gives
us this talk about safe sex and all that
stuff
and he's like oh we'll give you some
condoms i just want to make sure you
know how to use them
and like cool this guy whips out this
dirty plastic dildo and he's like i want
to see you guys put a condom on it
so she's there like and she does it and
she
patterns it just like
straight on ribbed done clean and he's
like cool
man gives me me the tea i remember he
gives me with two hands like that and
he's like james you said dildo with two
hands gave me the deal there were two
hands he's like james
and i was like oh so i had to peel the
thing and i just remember it being so
greasy
and i'm looking at this sweating clark
like yeah that's it yeah put it on
i'm like oh and then like i remember i
put it upside down so i'm like stroking
this plastic thing trying to
get it down because she did it fluid
like two finger thing just rolled down
and i'm like cool and i did it and it's
inside out so it only went this far and
is oh no it's inside out
and then like he like touched my hand
and like
pulled it off and then like we had to do
fam worst
experience of my life you know what that
reminds me of
what reminds me of that movie you just
spoke about in the other episode
oh with the pedophile like that from
nicaragua don't tell him
mike was a don't tell on me he was such
a creep and he was just sitting there i
just remember him being hunched over
sweating beading just like yeah yeah and
then like i just
remember stroking it down this dirty
dildo don't don't
how long ago this you were a kid right i
was like 16
15. so this was 13 14 years ago
like don't people that hire people
realize the impact that they've got on
kids
like when whoever hired my man did not
think like
he's gonna be the one presenting this to
teenagers
how is it gonna look fam
from the look of this place he was
probably a volunteer from
his oh my god his reaction oh my god
i don't think anyone paid him anything a
volunteer he was there for the joy of it
for the kick from when you said he
handed you the two hands
one pink dildo and not fluorescent pink
like
it was it was like the color of flesh
but like a really [ __ ] version
and it was just this white skinny gross
big dildo
that had a condom on and i i will never
forget looking at his greasy head
and feeling this greasy dom and just
thinking this
is not sex this is [ __ ] gross
like i don't want anything to do with
this and you said man touched you to
like
take it off and flip it
fam i want to rock him he's probably i'm
going to rock him he's probably impacted
there's no way like after that as well
like
the last thing i wanted to do was [ __ ]
my girlfriend yeah oh [ __ ] though i
think that's why they let him do it
because beard's gonna come in and
they're gonna leave and the last thing
they want to do is have sex
teenage sex is so gross man said was
probably a volunteer
i think he probably was fam this place
was shady
so we left with our plastic bag full of
condoms and one of the condoms was so
cheap
was so cheap it came
what
what are the condoms they're condoms
obviously they had durex cars they're
these brand next brands i don't know
where they find them
one of them was in a packet that looked
like um
what's the chewing gum it might be like
trident okay yeah
you pop open the packet and it comes in
the sticks like that that's tried in
here
exactly look like that so you pop open
this condom packet
and there's literally like strips of it
there so it's no
no squirting it's like little strips so
you pull it out i'm like what's this
you pull it out and you open it and it's
the cheapest
[ __ ] condom you've ever seen fab it
was like
uh it was like a sandwich bag
it wasn't elastic at all it was like a
little bag
and had a drawstring at the bottom no no
elastic band at the bottom
i had a drawstring so you had to put it
on and then tie the string
you have to tie the string you have to
tighten it and then like a shoelace spin
yeah it's a tiny string like a shoelace
on your tool
and then try and [ __ ] on it that's the
worst experience fam
and me and this girl were [ __ ]
so i we use all the good ones so i had
to use the trident thing
it slid off it slid off immediately
it was the shittiest thing it was the
worst [ __ ] thing
ever what the [ __ ] oh bro it sucks
it was so short like absolutely it was
absolutely it sounds like this so
needless to say condoms are [ __ ] yeah
long story short
oh god my kid is dirty [ __ ] johnny's
broth
ah look i feel sick
ah have you ever seen random
have you ever thought if you die in your
dreams you die in real life
nope never thought that you've never
thought of it nope what are you talking
about
have you ever been in in a situation in
your dream where you think you're about
to die though
oh right yeah um
but it's usually like falling off a
cliff or something but have you ever
died in your dream or do you wake
yourself does it wake you up it always
wakes me up
always wakes me up so then you must your
subconscious must think that if you die
in a dreamy day real life then
do you know what i mean oh that's the
reason it wakes me up no i'm just saying
i'm assuming
i'm assuming because the shock of it
feels so because the dreams feel real to
you
yeah because i remember wondering
vividly i don't know why
i don't know why i was in a room and
we were all lying down tied up it was
[ __ ] scary
man there was like seven of us in a row
and it was someone someone walking
beside us walking along us alongside of
us
yeah yeah killing us and then we were
automatically reviving again
and this was in my dream yeah and i saw
it happen to like
four people and i i was like two left to
go
so it was at the end it happened to the
second one
i was like shot him like five seconds
later they revived
if i'm shaking you know when you've got
like sleep paralysis
i was shaking to wake up oh my god
shaking to wake up
yeah yeah and obviously i woke up i
don't think i've ever died in my dream
yeah because i feel like your body would
actually feel like you're dying in real
life
potentially i've always woken up yeah
dreams [ __ ] me up boy if they're [ __ ]
has there ever been a moment or a time
in your life where you've had recurring
dreams every time you sleep you have the
same dream
or like in like the space of a week you
have the same repetitive dream
sorry yeah i don't remember what dream
it was same
i know it's happening definitely there's
definitely been times
where yeah i've had the same recurring
dream
and there's also been times like you
know when people talk about like deja vu
and they say deja vu is like um
[Music]
the song that's behind asia is like like
a slight delay in between like what your
eyes are seeing and then your
brain's receiving so it looks like
you've seen it twice or something like
that
i'm certain there's [ __ ] that's happened
to me oh without a shout out at least
50 times and it's not deja vu it's not
well yeah
i'm i've dreamt it do you know what i
mean like i've i'm seeing [ __ ] happen
and i'm like i've dread this
this is happening 100 percent dripless
so i know what's gonna happen next yeah
i i know what's gonna happen in this one
yeah yeah because you don't really know
yeah i know exactly what you mean that's
happened to me bear time
it's happened to me so many times you
sound like a widow if you say out loud
yeah a hundred percent
hundred percent it's happened to me so
many times you just sound like a chat
[ __ ] are you just
you just mutter to yourself [ __ ] out
deja vu yeah 100
like it's weird um am i the [ __ ] am i
the also
that was weird why an episode
fat mike he was a disgusted little
bastard
the funny thing about that he reminds me
he doesn't remind me of a
of any cartoon character but i feel like
it would be
funny if he was like a character in like
f is for family kind of thing
do you know oh yeah he'd be such a good
sketch character he'll be jokes and
anime if he was an animation
he'd be hilarious hilarious he's not
like a main character he would just pop
in like every other episode or so
that'll be jokes that's the first thing
i thought when you were describing him
[ __ ] that's gross mantida dom i've never
seen
a shoestring condom before i haven't
seen it since
that's mind-blowing to me they must be
they must be out of production
i hope so because i've never seen
anything like it i've never seen
anything like it well it's disgusting
never heard of anything like it
where is it
next week guys is one year it is
next week is the one year aniv anniversa
[ __ ] you know it's been a year almost
guys a [ __ ] year
thank you for rocking with us thank you
for laughing with us
thank you for telling people thank you
for
[ __ ] out i don't know thank you for
appreciating us thank you for
i don't know it's crazy it's crazy to
think it's going to be a year
it doesn't feel like it it's flowing by
but loads of shits happened
loads of shits happened loads of shits
happened
loads of [ __ ] happened and um it makes
me think like
when i listen because i listen to so
many podcasts and loads of the ones that
i listen to are like
three years in five years in like joe
rogan's like
10 years in um another one i listened to
is like seven eight years in now
and i'm like hell imagine all the shits
that's gonna happen by the time we reach
like year seven you're eight year ten
like that's bonkers it's a long way away
it is a long way it's a long way away
and we were talking about like
locations and stuff yesterday and i'm
like i'm gonna miss this white wall yeah
yeah i'm gonna miss this basic setup
that we have yeah yeah
um yeah this white wall is clean
it does the job and it's just like it's
not fancy or anything like that and now
i'm looking forward to looking back oh
yeah i'm looking forward to looking back
um five years from now and looking back
at some of these old episodes and being
like jesus christ what are we doing do
you remember we were under a year in and
we were just there in front of that
[ __ ] white wall broth i think about
that a lot
i think that a lot yeah i've never
voiced it but i think about that a lot
it's crazy it's crazy and it's cool it's
cool man
i think it's cool like i like looking
forward about stuff like that and it's
like
like we say it's weird like earlier we
were both tired and it's just like
it's work man it's work to make sure
everything's set up right making sure
we've got the content ready make sure
camera's ready lights are ready mike's
ready um
sometimes obviously like i said we have
to record loads in a bunch and stuff
like that when we're not going to see
each other very often
and just ah his work has worked but as
soon as like we're here now
i'm awake i'm awake and when i'm here
i'm awake now as soon as
soon as the camera rolls as soon as we
start talking about the first thing i'm
i'm here
and you can imagine like three four five
six years in
it's gonna be the same thing i think
it's cool man
i'm excited but yeah anyway i'm
next week's going to be fun um right
am i the [ __ ] for ignoring you're
you're like this one i might
[ __ ] for ignoring a child in the
grocery store
so off the bat
no cool not that big of a deal
but i was not his child um
it's not his or her child off the bat
not that big of a deal but i was grocery
shopping and had
um air pods in so i could listen to this
book that i'm uh enjoying
um but also i could also still hear if
anyone needed me
um i had my list out and one of those
carts because i'm too short to use one
of those mini cards because i'm too
short to use the big ones i don't care
um so i've got an invalid context yeah
people love to put random [ __ ] valid
unless it's relevant to the team it's so
irrelevant
right when i was going down the aisle i
heard someone say hi and i just kept
going about my business
it happened again and i glanced up
really quickly and i saw a kid sitting
in a car
waving and saying hi to everyone that
walked by
i ignored the kid and walked by so i
could finish my shopping
ignoring this kid was apparently the
most offensive thing humanly possible
because the mom glassed up and saw me
ignoring
um without responding saying hi back
and she said excuse me and i glanced up
because i thought she was trying to get
by me or something so i said what
and she said my son said hi to you i
said uh
okay and i continued down the aisle
she said when someone says hello to you
you usually say hello back
that's the polite thing to do i said
yeah sure okay
and then i shook my head and continued
down that aisle we crossed path several
times
that's all good through the rest of the
storm and she
glared at me fiercely and said hello
in a very weird like mocking voice i
don't know
anyway when i got to the cash out lane
uh she got
to one nearby and kept loudly talking to
the kids saying some people just don't
know how to be polite these days
it's okay baby everyone loves you
i'd had enough of the weird behavior so
i scooted around
on my way out and got down to the kids
level and yelled hello
and then looked at the woman and said
hello
why aren't you paying attention to me
hello
[Laughter]
yes yes rags because she
cracked up and so did the woman behind
her but she looked
like she was about to start crying i
feel kind of bad
but baby you're the mum the mum i feel
kind of bad but
also like for [ __ ] sake lady teach the
kid that sometimes people don't want to
[ __ ] talk to you
with 100 percent that's the funniest of
my house i've ever read ah
i i pictured myself as the guy in the
in the store yeah thinking why the [ __ ]
does the mom think
the kid has a the kid has a right to
every response
you know what i mean like some parents
think their kids are god's [ __ ] gift
people people make the mistake parents
make the mistake of thinking that
other people give a [ __ ] about their kid
as much as they do i don't give a single
[ __ ] about your kid i don't give a [ __ ]
it's not my kid stop telling man to say
hello to random people in the [ __ ]
store like
how can you expect people to stop and
say hello to your [ __ ] kid
and then confront them confront them
don't ever confront me for ignoring your
kid
confront them i don't know you i don't
know the kid [ __ ] you get on my face
[ __ ] you both
fam they remind the reason i said you'd
like it
obviously not the [ __ ] this is
standard that's like open and shut casey
i know what you're gonna say anyway
what am i going to say you're going to
say every time mandan would leaflet come
by me
i just [ __ ] ignore that the brain of
my existence
it's the banana the ways to ignore
lethal at people
is literally the funniest thing it's
like you are in a parallel
dimension you don't see them or hear
them or acknowledge them whatsoever i've
got [ __ ] to do
i'm on road and the worst thing is as
soon as you said
man had his ear pointed reminiscent
yeah i've there's so many times i've got
my earpods in i'm walking to the gym or
walking to work
and people especially nowadays when you
can't really see their face because
everyone's wearing masks yeah
they're just staring at me and i'm like
okay
and then i'm walking let's say we're
walking up opposite directions yeah
walking towards me i think what the [ __ ]
do you want
you can clearly see me listen to music
mind my own business yeah yeah yeah
and then coming up and they're like
standing in front kind of thing and it's
like
and they asked me like do you know the
directions oh big man
big man you could have asked anyone
don't ask if you've got headphones in
don't
ever ask me [ __ ] i'm interrupting i keep
headphones in
when i'm not listening to [ __ ] just like
people leave me the [ __ ] alone
it's so annoying it's so annoying so
annoying
oh yeah i would ignore the [ __ ] out that
kid i would have ignored the [ __ ] out of
that child
i'm so happy you went back to where i
was like hello and looked at her mom and
said hello
because it shows you how much of an
[ __ ] you are yeah bro you [ __ ]
idiot some people don't have to be
polite oh egg you fam
i will run to the dairy r when i'll
start egging you
oh some people think they're entitled to
everybody bro some people are crazy
everyone loves you baby shut the [ __ ] up
no we don't say no we don't
not everyone loves you i don't know you
i don't know you
who do you think you are
do you know what i mean yeah
you live in a bubble you live in a
[ __ ] barbecue
i remember there was one time right i
was with my ex-girlfriend at the time
and we sat in the i don't know where we
were
maybe we're in a doctor's office or
something it was somewhere where we had
to sit down and be quiet i can't
remember
but we were sat there it was somewhere
like a doctor's office okay
and next to us was the fattest baby
i've ever seen in my
life bro i'm talking not baby fat this
kid's
big yeah like i think the kid must have
had an issue with like
human growth hormone or something the
[ __ ] fat
kid i've seen is that baby was it a kid
it was a baby bird looked like a kid
head was massive everything was massive
and fat and the nan was like
rocky there i wasn't laughing at the
baby yeah
but i laughed at my girlfriend's
reaction in it kind of if you like you
were there yeah yeah
and like i looked at the baby and i was
like oh in my head i'm like oh my god
and i i looked at her like my girlfriend
at the time and then like
she looked at me didn't know that i was
i didn't even sign her to look at the
baby but she like made eye contact with
me
saw the baby in her peripheral while
she's looking at me looked down and
gasped
and then we just stared at each other in
silence and i was biting holes in my
tongue not to smile
and then the nun my girlfriend time's
here
i'm here the baby's here on the
right-hand side so we've done really
opposite each other
all i saw was that nan's head invade our
personal space
and was like something [ __ ] funny is
it it's something [ __ ] funny
do you want to say something no
and i was like then i did laugh yeah and
i was like
what who are you and she was like
something [ __ ] funny you want to
[ __ ] say something and then the kid's
mum was there like mom so calm down calm
down she's like nah nah nah you want to
say something and i was like big man
stop because i was speaking in my head
i'm getting angry now because i wanted
to be like
your kid's [ __ ] fat that's what i
want to say get your nasty head i can
smell your breath
get on my face get on my face i will say
something
run up on me [ __ ] [ __ ] people
have the audacities but i was thinking
we actually didn't say anything
and i actually wasn't even laughing at
the baby i was laughing at her reaction
but we made such little reference
to this kid that she lives on such and
obviously it's a defense mechanism yeah
but she's living in such a weird place
and an insecure place
that she saw two people in her general
area acting a little bit dodgy
because this is all all that's happened
is i've looked
looked at her she's kind of looked and
when i say she gasped she wasn't like
but i saw her like i could tell no one
but it's it was never enough for the nam
to like pick up on it yeah
but she saw a weird little something
and jumped to the conclusion that we're
mocking this baby
and i was just like big man get out my
face before i say something you you live
in a body yeah you need to relax and you
need to understand social construct
regardless if that's what you think you
can't just be running up in people in
public
shouting and screaming like was anyone
else around in this bear people
no everyone was looking nah that's when
i got defensive things now everyone's
looking at me nah
nah it was the weirdest thing this baby
was fat
[ __ ] i can't comprehend it you can't it
was
it was like it was literally
breathtaking
they must have had a hormone disorder
michelin types
literally like a michelin tire man
literally at the michelin man
that's what the baby looked like i was
gobsmacked
gobsmacked the head was massive
everything was out of pop oh it was mad
but anyway let's wrap it up fam all
right
see you guys later